Okay. Let's see how you did with the concept map. We know that there are two
copies of the human genome in every cell,
and cells make up tissues, which make up organs,
which make up the body. Cells, tissues, organs,
and the body together Manifest traits, which are influenced
by the human genome. And we learned a
bit about traits in lesson one. So the human
genome resides in the cell, and it can be divided into the nuclear genome
and the mitochondrial genome. The mitochondrial genome
has one circular chromosome per mitochondria, and there
are many mitochondria per cell. Now the
nuclear genome there's only one nucleus and
one nuclear genome per cell. But each
nuclear genome contains 23 pairs of linear chromosomes,
22 pairs are called the autosomes. They're
numbered based on their size from 1-22. One
being the biggest and 22 being the smallest. But one pair of the 23 pairs of
chromosomes are called sex chromosomes. And these determine
the sex of the individual. Two X chromosomes
will develop as a female, and then X and Y chromosome will develop as a male.
All chromosomes in a cell are made
of nucleic acid wrapped around histone proteins.
Now there are two different types of nucleic acid, and one of them, DNA, is
what makes up chromosomes. The other type,
RNA, we'll learn more about in lesson three.
DNA is composed of deoxynucleotides. There are
four different types of deoxynucleotides that all differ
in which nitrogenous base they contain. There's adenine, or A, which can base
pair with thymine, or T. And cytosine, or C, can base pair with guanine, or G.
Now DNA is double-stranded and comes in
a helical shape. But the double-stranded nature
of DNA is held together by base
pairs. Which are formed by the nitrogenous bases.
And one human genome, one copy, is made of 3 billion base pairs of DNA.